what you doing James Franco Oh what is
going on for you too now I'm not
somebody who likes to pry in people's
personal life yes I do
but recently I heard through the
grapevine James Franco was trying to hit
on a little baby baby James Franco and
guess what oh no you didn't do it on
your Instagram not on your Instagram
James Franco you should already know
that button on your Instagram is how you
done get trapped and you sir does got
trapped
aren't you the instagrams selfie master
you should know the rule now some people
say that this is a marketing ploy for
the new film and he's going to be in
that's going to come up [ __ ] what's
that movie called seventeen old enough
but Love Actually she's underage
Kindergarten Cop the love story Oh James
Franco bet you a spider-man will save
yes now you filthy animal why would you
want a seventeen-year-old you are old
enough to be huh Danny if you were 18 at
time and you're not a girl let me on Sam
every time a celebrity reaches the
pinnacle of their career they got to do
something stupid to [ __ ] it up
now we all know that a good handful of
these actors and actresses are freaks
but before they didn't have social media
to blow it up boy you are everywhere you
better kick your freaky ideas on the
inside you know who I slowly begun to
realize is that social media has [ __ ]
up a lot of people hasn't it for example
it's so easy to find somebody and beat
their ass down in because everybody
loves the geotag themselves whatever
they go and then you wonder how the [ __ ]
they keep finding ass
how'd you find me bullies because you
keep geo-tagging yourself on your face
[ __ ] look around here look see ah you
still gonna shoot me haha of course what
you think I mean I heard that you manned
up to it and you admitted that you did
it but it still don't change the fact
you a dirty ass animal you're just gonna
wait till she was 18 cut your hump the
patient little [ __ ] hmm Otto
what anybody says that is still a
promotion for his movie coming up you
don't know [ __ ] if you live in LA you've
been doing this for a while
you know people start making up [ __ ]
to always cover their asses ah nice try
you touch babies James Franco come on
she was an e-2 yo Adam and you took the
jailbait do you have any idea what this
does for people like me in terms of
jokes I'm gonna make up a lot of [ __ ] by
now
J Franco the type of do the drive up to
a junior high be like to young James
brake on the top of there to go to a
daycare and look for life James Franco
the type of dude to watch Sesame Street
like a softcore porno James Franco the
type of dude I think the Magic School
Bus is an anime porn James Franco the
type of dude to read you a bedtime story
after you date yup oh man James Franco
watch James Franco you could have any
girl that you want but you just want the
forbidden fruit I feel like after a
certain point celebrities realize that
they can get any type of person that
they want so they just want a challenge
and because of that I'm a firm believer
that's why people be [ __ ] donkeys
regular vaginas too easy for these
[ __ ] they gotta go exotic hey
James Franco yeah once there oh no
thanks I [ __ ] a peacock tonight I was
going on YouTube ah the hair is growing
steady and I am continually losing
pounds slowly but surely I will get
there so they cut his [ __ ] to go but
yes that was a hot topic suggested by
you guys mr. James Franco come on man
stop [ __ ] around make good films you
made a great one with uh what's it
called all those [ __ ] and this
is the end that [ __ ] was funny I left
but hey people out there stop touching
babies and remember go for broke apparel
it's coming out with a new you know new
[ __ ] starting next week and once again
the new line that we keep on coming out
with every time it releases there's
gonna be sale it's gonna be on a
discount which I know you [ __ ]
been loving and of course you guys know
that funny fat bit is coming up I'm not
leaving y'all hang because I got a hurry
if they get rid of this [ __ ] hair so
I will see you then and remember ha see
y'all next time
sup pac man that's a Korean packing I
shat on mush good Bob huh say what that
laughing come on dude don't laugh at
your own jokes that's unprofessional
reaches the pinnacle of their career
corel car all mother [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
plane half go to fry Oh in the house
hand [ __ ] [ __ ] you man come here
with a payment [ __ ] but enough man I
will kill somebody